are you almost can we start matt yeah
i'm good to go you want to just start up
come on peters have like at least a sip
it's nice when you have at least a sieve
can i lean in with music matt
who's this
it's like this uh music that was called
like uh cosmic bachelor music are we on
right now you're wrong oh yeah all right
cosmic bachelor
jesus man the style of music gives it
like uh let me look it up
for up in my big mouth i feel like i'm
on vacation in the philippines or
something
we welcome you miss american man yeah
they put a lay on you
hey hey folks here we are we're doing it
we might be drunk we're back sammy fatty
we got the beer jew we got uh google
[ __ ] salaccus in the house we're
cooking google [ __ ] that's what's
called him now i hope i'm sorry dude
he was aiming for superman with that
shirt
[ __ ] no soup for you we're going google
it
oh yeah nuggets for you though today yes
salukis was nice enough to bring in some
nugs what a good guy he knows he's on
thin ice so he's trying to you know
bring in something nugget please
oh my god
denver what i'm saying please
[Laughter]
easy rogan all right
but yeah we're cooking i haven't seen
you we haven't done an up in a while it
feels like it's been a minute man yeah
how you doing good i'm excited listen to
this run i got cooking
la jolla this weekend i was just there
you were just there beautiful it's it's
magical over there yeah shout out to
billy bonnell who super funny guy uh and
alec parent who's very funny as well i
feel like billy is one of those dudes
who's been at it a while though and
doesn't get his due so check out billy
bonnell there's a great uh
little short dock on him and he had a
tragic life i don't know billy bonnell
he did house party back in the day you
know he's the movie no uh [ __ ] oh
adam devine sorry sorry you did that oh
no you know the one before i did john
oliver wow i did house party okay okay
um uh that was back when comedy central
had a couple stand-ups on their shows
you know back in those days like when
mtv played music
we don't have to at this point on comedy
central it's like it's like [ __ ] on
a sink that's already gone down it's
like [ __ ] with a person in a
wheelchair like it's literally like
we're on the getaway boats in that
titanic and we're just flicking off the
boat
um no billy there's a dock on him and
like his upbringing which is like
you know spoiler like not too much of a
spoiler but he's had a pretty tragic
upbringing and he talks about it and he
makes it he makes it funny good guy
funny guy check out billy bought now all
right and uh
the beach in la jolla ah it's one of
those clubs you're like how does this
work the beach is three blocks away
everybody here is gorgeous they're tan
they're blonde they surf all day they
drink all night they [ __ ] they do molly
and they're cool and they're cool
there's no guard that's why they're cool
that's right but la has that but they're
all entitled
precious [ __ ] you know what is that why
is it i guess san diego it's like l.a
minus showbiz that's what it is and for
some reason that lowers the although la
jolla is super expensive to live it is
yeah but it's it you minus the showbiz
and it's people that are just kind of
chill people living and the weather's
perfect and there's a crisp in the air
and the sunshine is warm so yeah it's
just good living out there it's la
people that don't look over your
shoulder while you're having a
conversation that's what la jolla is
that's what san diego san diego some of
the best mexican food oh
amazing there's a burrito stand i think
it's called taco stand yeah yeah
california burrito incredible guys in
the burrito
yeah dude that's a hangover cure right
there yeah a lot of good stuff there uh
i had a great time
uh eight shows i was i was having a
blast man you write a lot when you're
doing oh yeah many shows so so what is
it two thursday two friday three
saturday two saturday two sunday one
give me three saturday max me at eight i
would i would have spent a week there if
they let me hell yeah it's a nice little
getaway i can't wait uh i'm pretty
pumped but then okay so i do that great
it's gonna be a great way i got zoltan
opening i got parent uh you're gonna
love him hosting yeah then
fly to utah
going skiing with ari shane gillis
kreischer um derosa sean patton
that's gonna be insane oh my god what
are we drinking here is this this isn't
the rusty nail again is it no no this is
not the risky nail again this is
basically a little twist on the classic
whiskey sour
different sweeteners in there like st
germain and we're doing a little
granular year to give it a little cognac
punch too so it should be nice what's it
called
you know what i didn't come up with the
name
oh
how about the twisty sour hey
twist in the whiskey right i like it i
like it twisty hey hey
bottoms up
ooh that's smooth dude
jesus christ it's why are you doing this
to us i could have eight of these it's
not too sweet it's still got a kick i
love it the whiskey riff
the whiskey riff that's not bad that's
good yeah i like it
dude
you know what whiskey sour makes me
think of every time is for some reason
something about mary cause that's
there's that one scene where matt matt
dylan on the you know on the water is
like give me a whiskey sour oh yeah man
he stole that movie for me you know he's
like ah yeah you know that kid's a manga
lloyd's got a good
foreign like a drive-in movie theater i
love when they go to his office and he
shakes his hand his pants are down i
mean everything is great that's one of
those movies that we'll show our kids
and they'll and they'll be like this is
problematic and this is comedy i know
this is what humor is this is brilliant
this is like the peak of fairly dad
you're so you're so cheesy
you think this is funny cheesy what's
gold i know people will say these kids
are they're going to be watching uh
there we go
now this paper bag is funny this is this
is art no one gets hurt there's it's
there's no victim shut up excuse me i
ordered a whiskey sour
[Laughter]
delivery why didn't matt dylan get more
comedies he's so good i know he really
is
he's so good his brother his brother
might have ruined it for him johnny
drama oh that's right because he's so
good he's good too yeah but he's the
loser he plays the loser so well well
he's not playing always we're stalking a
woman in this man he's not a cool guy
he's just he's just a good looking dude
so you're not thinking that's the genius
of that movie you don't realize how
creepy the plot is because every
character is so likable that's true yeah
you ever had a white head on your
eyeball yeah remember harlow williams in
that he was killer oh he was
and dumb and dumber oh man pull over
it's a cardigan
sipping on grandpa's cup as in
oh man let's get the hell out of here
get the hell out of here
so good six minute abs killer oh yeah
something about mary i watched recently
it holds up oh yeah lee evans incredible
lee evans he's great in that you two
should be kissing my hairy [ __ ] bean
bag
the scene where he just hits him and he
breaks the accent i love her man
that's [ __ ] great they show his
driver's license he's got the long hair
he's a total hippie ah it's so good
classic
so
you got you got salt lake which is a
beautiful place we're going to park city
we're doing one night of shows three
shows that's it's paying for the whole
weekend we got a huge house with a hot
tub we got ski equipment already taken
care of with all these do you guys all
know how to ski i'm on a snowboard do
you know to snowboard i do yeah
how do you learn that i'm not great well
i used to skateboard for years so it's
pretty similar you know you're standing
sideways
it's i'm you know i pick it up i fall
the first hour but then i get it i'm
always that's how people die oh sunday
when neeson's wife died is that right
yeah not snowboarding skiing she was
taking impact
sonny bono
you missed marx
bono yeah yeah bobby mcferrin i think
broke both leg skiing don't worry be
happy
yeah skiing will get you it'll get you
that's something that probably will go
away in like 50 years
well it's literally
so de it's just on the snow going around
trees you know
hills
slope i don't know it just feels so
dangerous
also there won't be snow
so what are the sleeping quarters like
there all these comics in one house yeah
we got a giant house and there's you
know a bunch of bedrooms everyone's got
their own room yeah last time we went i
gave everyone a vd did you all got in
the hot tub naked drunk and i apparently
i had something cooking and it just
seeped out the hot tub
yeah this guy ryan o'neal was there he
almost got divorced because his wife's
like what the [ __ ] he's like i swear to
god it's from a dude you know it's just
like what yeah it's the whole thing yeah
you can get that [ __ ] from like towels
you can get it from like a traveler
don't ask me how i know the towel one
but uh is that right yeah
yeah what a bummer a towel yeah
roommates yeah we shared a towel whoa
yeah and i was like what the hell and
they're like yeah this is i think that's
from a town which one how serious are we
talking aids uh yeah i knew it i have
aids but luckily uh it's cured by a
whiskey riff yeah
alcoholism cures aids you got that right
it's uh no i forgot what it was it was
like some it was just some like fungal
[ __ ] i was like
20 or something but it's you know went
away quickly but it was like man this is
[ __ ] this is embarrassing yeah i just
learned that jock itch and yeast
infection are the same thing hanley's
got a bit about it oh he does it yeah
yeah oh wow good about how he thought he
had it but he had a yeast infection
yeah i was boinking a soccer player in
college she was a pretty hot little lady
but she was always you know kicking and
screaming and uh you know the sunshine
the the
you know
it was a swamp downtown yeah and so i'd
catch her after a game she'd be all hot
and bothered you know we'd go at it and
uh no hands but uh you know we'd go at
it and then yeah and uh i got a jock
itch from her i got it i had it for like
eight months i couldn't get rid of it
wow it burned like hell it itched it was
gross
geez you know how i got rid of it hot
tub
yogurt
really there's cultures and yogurt that
kill the fungus so i was eating tubs of
yogurt today took you took some gogurt
you sprayed some on your nuts
yeah it looks like jizz anyway
yeah so that was it yogurt you just eat
a lot like activia is that yes exactly
you need those cultures they have the
whole activity ad campaign jamie lee
curtis is like just like do you have
diarrhea like she didn't say it but it
was it was basically like this is if you
have diarrhea that was the whole ad
pretty much like you're old your bowels
are gross eat this and eat the fiber
that she was too hot i know should be
doing a diarrhea add i feel like you
have to be a little older to be doing
you have to be at least 70. yeah give
that to ellen barkin or something give
it to robert wagner
remember those ads reached peak sadness
when uh
some woman came on and she's like oh hey
you're the activia lady she's like i'll
take that she's like she accepted her
role
she said that yeah
she doesn't get her due as a hot lady
she doesn't because there was that weird
hermaphrodite was that real no but it
was a rumor
when there's a rumor yeah i thought it
was real
it's not the only thing you
did you spread it in the tub
i'd love to give her a little
little feel
yeah oh yeah for sure
yeah she looked good in knives out
yeah yeah not bad she's older she's
older yeah pretty older woman there she
is yeah but like still still you know
nice looking i think she was considered
a hot lady for sure i mean true lies
yeah
good point the true lie scene raise your
hand if you never masturbated to the
true lie scene yeah that's what i
thought
touched that's what i thought come
closer to the bed
that was hot that's a good movie great
movie great movie the only time i
enjoyed tom arnold
really ah
yeah he's he's a lot he is a lot but
he's kind of fun he's fun look at that
she was in that movie perfect with
travolta look at that lady that is
awesome that's what you were talking
about there's a photo of her out there
see if you can find that's it with the
red and the sunglasses pull up that
photo jesus christ the sun goes insane
oh my lord oh
i can imagine walking around like that
come on and a dick too i'll take it a
few a few of our listeners just stopped
watching to uh to jack off we lost them
you got that right they've had a few
drinks they're like we'll see you guys
we're going to pause we'll be back later
also to have the short hair i feel like
short hair is tough for a late a lot of
ladies but you with her you're like yeah
another like really hot actress short
hair mariska hargitay for sure sure
natalie portman for a minute had short
hair she's really pretty
oh barry's another one obviously oh
jesus christ this is pretty porn too so
that's all you need
all right i gotta get out of here this
is all right the podcast is over you
guys have been great we'll see you next
week
[Laughter]
what do you think we can get to travolta
where's travolta the vault is not bad we
gotta get the travolta this is also back
when you didn't have to have an ass oh
yeah those are good uh good days for
white women
yeah all right is this what the pot has
become we're like those guys outside of
the department store staring at the tv
what the hell is going on
oh wow this was a movie that's how horny
people were
like we'll go sell paid 12 to see that
that's true yeah damn i mean i was
looking at you know victoria's secret
catalogs and bra ads back in the day
oh yeah
and what little do we know he's a big
gay
is he oh what are you kidding have you
heard the masseuse though i heard maybe
he's bi we don't know if he's just
getting all right he's probably probably
buy he does have kids and uh i've heard
them stories
look at that he's just shaking it that's
what it sounds so weird that's a weird
uh workout for a guy
i don't know if you have to work with
your [ __ ] vagina muscle right he's
doing kegels
[Laughter]
john travolta's got the tightest [ __ ]
event
yeah you need a little grease if you're
going to get in there
travolta is a man though oh i like the
stefano did oh yeah he told me
great yeah
hopefully that one's out by now
matt's saying yes thank you so uh
you got salt lake what else so go and
ski in front of the white clubs too wise
guys i'll be there in april with gary
veeder and i think it's
the first playoff game
is saturday so i'm hoping it's a day
game we're [ __ ] going if there's a if
there's a day utah jazz game you know
we're going and the stadium's across the
street from the club basically i know
wow that'll be amazing that'll be dope
i'll root against them because i want
donovan mitchell to come to new york
oh there you go man what you would feed
her he's like your make-a-wish kid you
take him to games and sold out clubs
lollipop
hat with a propeller a balloon
where else you going so then so tampa
i'm [ __ ] la jolla skiing in utah and
then straight to tampa for side
splitters tampa love it love seismic no
green room but hey you're next to like a
[ __ ] xerox machine i'm like how do
you have a xerox machine but not a green
room i know right the hell's going on
what year is it you got a beta max
hopefully bobby jewel will he make an
appearance he'll probably pop in and
call me a [ __ ] does he so if you're
listening you don't know bobby jewel is
uh the legend who used to run tampa side
switch yes
exactly what you're picturing jewelry
rings crazy car with a convertible bad
toupee charlie sheen two and a half men
shirt yes yes that weird bowling kind of
shirt and uh some some coos on his arm
you know [ __ ] house wasted
rolls up drunk in a convertible mercedes
gets this close to your face yeah smells
whiskey breath and it'll be like you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that leave pieces of [ __ ] like you in
the dirt yeah and you just can't help
but laugh yeah he's the man and then he
sits down and tells you stories and you
don't really care but you listen and
it's fun oh he'll he'll pick you up
drunk blasting jersey boys you're
driving the car swerving all over the
road big girls don't cry
oh yeah then he cooks you a steak in his
underwear it's great
he looks like an out of work uh like
detective in miami oh dude he's classic
i can't wait to i'll be there in june i
can't wait yeah this drink goes down a
little too easy too easy there the beard
jew comes through again with the whiskey
riff
so good so yeah then i come back to new
york the lady's furious she's like
you're gone for eight years you're
skiing you're going to tampa you're
going to [ __ ] california but i'm like
hey
this is the business i've chosen it's
not though you've been on a mini
vacation in between good point
with comedians i could write it off
reader's got a joke about how he just
well like you know we'll hang out all
day so his wife will be pissed yeah he's
at one of the lines he's like we're the
strip club he's like honey i go where
the work takes me
it's true yeah well we got good lives
50 stories there from that uh that house
oh it's gonna be wild what was the
energy like oh well i went last time
yeah
they had a steam room and a hot tub and
so we'd all get naked this is so
homoerotic we'd get hammered we're all
in a blackout it's like midnight we're
getting naked hitting each other with
towels and then we would do a thing
where we'd run this does not sound like
a vacation to me
[Laughter]
we'd run we'd ski all day we'd get drunk
you know whatever and then we would get
drunk get the the hot no the the sauna
and we're all in there like god damn
we're so hot and then we'd run into the
snow naked and sit in the snow like ah
they would run to the hot tub and chug
beers and then make out
it was great
it was fun skiing by the way don't tell
it
it's insanely strenuous i i would never
want to do it yeah you're just like ah
after every muscle is sore your body
hurts
yeah
but nothing like that lodge though when
you're in that lodge with a beer and you
got you take your your gear off and whoo
you have a cup of chili the view the
view it's pretty nice yeah that's a good
show
yeah it'll be fun man
yeah so that can't wait can't wait damn
now what it would uh what do you got
cooking i was just in la jolla's great
oh yeah i'll give you a good rack but
please and this is uh my record is to
not be cheap
because it comes it comes back to get
you i don't know here's what happened to
me on my way to la jolla okay i'm at jfk
luckily i'm there a little i had like an
8 a.m flight yeah i know so i woke up at
like 5
then my flight gets delayed an hour but
i'm like hey man i i took a muscle
relaxer the night before i got six hours
i'm okay okay i'm gonna i'm i'm up i'm
not going back to sleep i try but i'm i
can't so i'm you know i'm up i'm there
about an hour early
and i go through security and my my
roller bag just falls apart just a while
to the point that like i'm on the
escalator and i didn't realize it just
whips open like it's all it's like
breaks in front of me my electric
toothbrush falls out the head is on the
floor oh this is
this is just my life
shambles here aka vibrator
let's be honest steven what happened to
stephen
[Laughter]
um
so yeah i'm furious and i'm just like
what do i do so i'm i'm lugging it like
you know
i'm holding it like a baby right
you know to a store i'm like come on you
guys have a bag like we only have little
ones and i'm like well where's the big
ones and she goes uh well i have stores
closed i'm like closed it's the airport
come on what the hell what the hell is
this junkyard you're running here so i
so i i keep walking around i find a
store that sells bags they look nice and
i'm like all right
what kind of bat i need a bag so what
can we do and she goes they start at 400
and i'm like you muzzleless piece of dug
i didn't say that i was just uh is this
is this tumi
no it was it was briggs and riley the
quality bag sure and i just go oh you
got me you got me all of you did you get
a 400 bag it gets worse oh no it starts
at 400 ah so you better believe that
first that 400 bag ain't that good yeah
it's not fitting all my stuff and i'm
just like what do i do and she goes
here's a this is the one for you and i'm
like yeah it's the only one that'll work
it's the only option at that point i
don't have a bag
so i'm nervous i get a 500 bag okay i'll
get i will say this it's a damn good bag
all right it better be i but i get the
bag
and i'm like you know what we travel
every week this is but and this is look
like a 200 bag instead of a 40 roller
bag the first time i wouldn't be in this
mess that's why don't be cheap is my
wreck because you save money by going
middle of the road rather than high end
or low end right right so
uh i get the bag and i'm like it's a
little smaller than my other bag i can't
get my jacket in there so some lady from
the store grabs the jacket she's like
pushing it in she's like punching it i'm
like lady give it i just bought this bag
yeah right she's like
jerking the [ __ ] thing and i'm like
i'm like lady stop he's like i got him
like stop and she won't stop thank god
she's not a guy no
jesus christ
either way i screamed rape but
she was going i was like stop stop and
then finally she got out like all right
thanks and then we're out of there and i
got to tell you
you realize what this money goes to
because i'm pulling the bag i'm like
this [ __ ] baby glide yes my other bag
i'm like oh this is why i probably have
shoulder problems yeah i'm just always
jerking it around
this baby it was like i could [ __ ]
jump on this bad boy and just ride the
waves right it's incredible you get what
you pay for you get what you pay for
well good for you and you'll have that
thing for 30 years i hope you it's a
lifetime guarantee oh
david tell him that great oh sorry hear
that great joke about the luggage you
you tell it well the joke yeah it's like
who's that who's that store for like how
late do you have to be running like [ __ ]
it just grab some stuff we'll pack when
we get there
[Laughter]
although this is what that store is for
club yeah there you go they just wait
for some guy's bag to break up they prey
on desperation
i bet someone in the [ __ ] uh you know
airport security line had a little axe
and just [ __ ] broke it so i had yeah
big [ __ ] airport conspiracy right
here big luggage yeah yeah i had the
same thing happen to me not at the
airport but uh i got a samsonite bag
which you know that's actually something
exactly samsonite slippy slappy swanson
so
but i got it at a thrift store but
either way it's a samsonite it's a good
bag great bag it glides you need a bag
of glides because you realize you're
like [ __ ] why am i you're jerking it on
hills and stuff exactly you're gonna
[ __ ] your body up i know and we don't
realize those bags get thrown around and
baggage claim we jam them up in those
overheads you know you throw them in a
car it's just so much wear and tear how
do professional wrestlers do it they're
traveling every week of the year they're
doing the wrestling they're flying and
then like we we our bodies are [ __ ] up
just from traveling i know it's well
they're on a ton of percocet and
oxycontin and all that [ __ ] so are we
good
if you have any pills by the way i'll
take them really well they help me sleep
i can't
sleep about anything
i'm not trying to do this i got a great
idea this is my lesson to mark you know
how you can get some pills get some
[ __ ] health insurance
[Laughter]
never
come on
we're going to ride this body into this
market's gonna be the richest comedian
who's gonna need a gofundme when he goes
and he goes into the hospital
well when my bike my hog got stolen the
cop was like all right i gave him all
the information he's like you know you
have no insurance on this thing i was
like well let's just find it first you
know really yeah yeah
good time sam by the way somebody said
they spot it in chinatown i'm gonna go
steal it back they spotted it yeah how
do you know it's yours well they took a
photo of it and it has these two slices
on it where i fell over once and i was
like that's mine
so i'm going back i'm gonna steal it do
you think the key is the same can you
just put the key in it i had the key
they they grabbed and put in the truck
so how do you get it i'm just gonna go
there with bolt cutters and
but then how do you start it without the
key no i have the key oh good i'm saying
i took the keys out and it got stolen
they just threw it on a bed of a truck
so i'm gonna try to steal it back how
are they riding it they must have do you
know they can hot wire [ __ ] they're
gonna change it up yeah damn oh yeah it
might be the different keys then you
gotta you gotta heist that [ __ ] i'm
gonna heist i might get beat up
i heard i heard someone threw dog [ __ ]
at list
yeah what the [ __ ] is happening in this
city kids you saw the lady get the dog
[ __ ] in the face yep hold on in the
bronx
smushed it in her face and her hair
crazy the city's back it's like the 80s
it's wild out here
then you go to la jolla and you're like
this is how people live and then you
come back here even the homeless people
look like hugh jackman there i know
exactly i'm like you want my money you
look better than i do what the hell
totally it's like i need a new surfboard
man
come on man don't be stingy yeah
yeah the lady with the the poop in there
it's a it's tough to watch
why are we watching it
you gotta see what we're up against here
man smears poop on woman in nyc subway
station sickening the new york post
lives for this [ __ ]
they have to act like they're outraged
but they're like a woman got smeared in
poop let's do it
i know they're high-fiving at the office
we got our front page story everyone
else is talking about ukraine
[Laughter]
run the poop story yeah
there it is here we go
okay was it on the two train
oh that's okay oh
and he comes back for more
bag of [ __ ] damn
whatever happened to a pie in the face
you know those were the good old days
the most disgusting part is the white
back to front yeah he really gave it a
wipe down he doesn't look homeless
either i know
he's got the hat with no broom how brim
is posted is it hi
damn they got a good shot of the guy's
face
oh they did it oh great
i don't know i don't know they just let
you go
it's got to be assault
i mean they're deadly oh like crazy like
willy-nilly they just arrest you and
then let you go the same day within
hours yeah epidemic here in the city
yikes well eric adams says he's cracking
down yeah we'll see what happens that's
poop on the face would you rather get
hit with a hammer or poop on the face
poop in the face me too but not by a ton
yeah that's a good question
poop in the face is rough yeah cause you
[ __ ] every day you just think about it
every day
yeah that's that smell is gonna stay
with you oh yeah oh yeah you gotta do a
secret you're gonna be on your death bed
you're gonna you're gonna remember the
poop it's gonna be you and your wife and
then it's gonna cut to the poop in the
face and like that even on my deathbed
that's true oh yeah yeah no i said i
prefer the poop
yes prefers the wrong word
i uh
oh man
crazy
you ever had that living here i mean not
that but like anything similar i was on
the train once this is i i've gotten ver
i think the train every day i've never
i've never been like attacked but like i
did have uh
i remember i was on the train once
coming down from the uh comic strip many
years ago i was on with uh this comedian
dan shacky we're honestly i love shacky
and
this guy is on some sort of drugs and
he's [ __ ] with me like he just you
know when you're on drugs you just find
one person you're gonna [ __ ] with yeah
he uh
he's like messing with me on the train
and he's just like in my face like i'd
sit down he'd sit right next to me and
like just start standing down with me
and then shaky and shaqui's looking like
what do we do kind of and i was kind of
like
yeah [ __ ] what do we do yeah big guy
could you take him i think i could like
you don't know because of the drug so
someone right on those drugs they have
like hulk strength that's true pcp he
and he's tweaking and you're like well
can i take him is the wrong question
like who has more to lose is the
question you know so
he sits and i'm like all right like this
guy's like rubbing up against me [ __ ]
with me i'm like
all right let's move so we move he does
he moves with me right next to me again
ah and i'm just like it's like stops go
by and shaki you know is going to a
story and i'm going to brooklyn so
uh
he's
he's like i gotta get off 59th i think
he's giving me a look like you're gonna
be okay and i kind of like
you know yeah uh
and then he gets off at 59th and i we're
going down and the guy keeps [ __ ]
with me jeez and i keep moving he keeps
moving too
and finally at my stop in my head i'm
like if he gets off and my stop at 14th
i was gonna transfer i was like if he
gets off where i get off i'm going to
say something
and uh i have to or follow me home yep
so
i'm trying to like play it cool and just
kind of act like nothing's wrong because
he's clearly tweaked out
i i get off he follows me up
and as he's following me off the door i
go i go back the [ __ ] off and he goes ah
and he falls back on the train the door
shut i was like whoa
i was like thank [ __ ] god and that's
how you met joe mac
wow yeah i was i was like god damn it
good for you though it worked i was like
this is this dude is like tweaked yeah
yeah wow i think maybe you just wanted a
friend in a weird way no he was he was
was he gonna be violent you think
he was [ __ ] with me i mean it was
like i mean i don't think shaky would
have been like what the hell either if
right
this is unbelievable you see this [ __ ]
on the train all the time i mean usually
you just avoid it but
you just know when there's a crazy
person right as a new yorker you just
know to just avoid avoiding like i
remember i was on the train with steve
fabricant from the cellar that one of
the door guys there
late night and there was like a crazy
guy [ __ ] with everyone steve is just
like zinging him and i'm like wow what
you want to have a you want to like have
a good burn on the crazy guy right i was
like this is not what new yorkers do we
avoid yes you don't you don't poke the
bear dude no no eye contact yeah one
time i had a zing in in my old
neighborhood new orleans and it was like
a bunch of black guys hanging out and
they were all in like school uniforms
and i was i don't know 11 12.
so they were all whatever and then i had
a zing and we're all on the sidewalk and
the school just got out and it was like
pretty much an all-black school and they
got me in this circle and they're
pushing me and i'm bouncing around the
circle like a pinball and they're all
laughing and pushing me and they're like
what a [ __ ] what a [ __ ] yeah you white
[ __ ] and i was like god i was so
embarrassed and i took a swing and i
missed i just got like an air ball and
they were like
and i was such a [ __ ] that might have
saved you it saved me they were like get
out of here you [ __ ] they kicked me
in the ass on the way out but it was you
had heart it was pretty traumatizing
though oh you know you walk home you're
like i should have done this i should
have jumped kicked the guy and
headlocked him and kung food him but
then then they grabbed another white guy
they're like let's go for the high score
bounce them around
yeah it was like pong i couldn't get
away but yeah pretty embarrassing so
it's good you didn't you don't ever you
know not the poke the the crazy person
ever yeah but
this is unreal this guy has balls of
steel smack me in the face i didn't cuz
you want to come over here i'm trying to
tell you that you know what are you
doing
i'm going to stand right there
i'm going to stand right here laughing
you just came over and smacked me did i
smack you in the face did anyone see me
smack him in the face no
i did not look at this guy's planted
feet not going anywhere
like everybody else
eye contact
and
that's not nice right
there is a bit of a payoff here it's
kind of funny let me fast forward yeah
yeah
subway we all touch each other it's
funny this is two and a half minutes
this guy probably thought this was three
hours
you ain't [ __ ] me that's right okay
here it is so he's he says i'm gonna
[ __ ] you right here as the guy said i'm
gonna [ __ ] you yeah yeah so the guy says
you're not [ __ ] me and then this is
where it gets good
are you trying to threaten him
yes he is thank you thank you ladies
you ain't [ __ ] nobody with me
standing right here that's what's
happening this guy is secretly ripped
you can see he's ripped under the button
down yeah he's huge he also has like
heavy corrections officer yes yes this
guy probably grew up in bensonhurst or
some [ __ ] you know he's seen it all he's
not scared of this guy you might
masturbate yeah oh there it was oh i
missed it sorry i stepped on it you
might masturbate what's happening
you ain't [ __ ] nobody you might
masturbate the [ __ ] off but you ain't
[ __ ] nobody
i love how his compromises go jerk off
on the train
that's checkmate checkmate
you can be gay
hey look at this guy open-minded
inclusive
good
he said i'm gay then he said i'm a
gangster yeah he's a gay gangster oh
anyway but what else that's it that's
pretty much it yeah they just kind of he
just walks away eventually damn pretty
awesome yeah you can't show weakness in
that situation yeah no that's the only
thing you have to fake it you have to
fake it even if you're scared you have
to fake it but that dude did look big
bigger than yes oh yeah oh yeah
good for him that guy i hope he gets
laid off that
you're the you're the tell off the crazy
homeless guy guy
i guess uh yes i am yeah but he wasn't
violent i mean obviously he was he was
down to throw but he wasn't violent he
liked the gays he wasn't like i'm gonna
kill you just like hey you're not
[ __ ] anybody i lost my hair at 25.
you don't think i'll lose my temper
we should have that guy on i want him on
that guy's awesome should we should we
try one of these donuts oh
baby where are they from
donut project right on mcdougall street
it's an everything donut buckle up uh-oh
it's like the pulp fiction briefcase
whoa
is that cream cheese
it's everything damn take one i want
some like i want some candy uh smoked
salmon
oh god
yeah holy cow you can hear that thing
breaking apart oh you want a piece come
on you're looking thin tell you
it's like my family
beard you
all right get your fat ass over here
yeah that's insane that's amazing take
that piece
thank you
you throw every everything seasoning on
anything you're not gonna do it um why
not fish it's great a little nervous
live a little all right take a [ __ ]
chance you got a cocktail in front of
you oh here you want a whole one just
throw me a small piece
all right
it's funny it's like a donut
i love it the problem that everything is
it's it's like confetti it goes
everywhere
like rip taylor over here
oh man it looks good
very good
mmm cream cheese frosting incredibly
underrated too good call
oh that's a smear smear smear yeah
um
got nuts in it
love it oh yeah that's that's what the
viewers want for us to be sucking our
fingers from that podcast
we just lost everybody can you tell me
the role of pt
there you go
take a pull
pass it around
no that's living huh good teacher really
seems to get all right that's a great
donut all right did you do a wreck yeah
i did the uh i got a couple but that's a
good one no that's that's really my main
wreck what do you got that's a good one
um
going out back to our roots
we reckon some all weird [ __ ] all over
the road
mullany
monologue on snl i gotta watch it
masterful incredible one of the best one
of the best sadly he's like he's like my
age he might be younger than me it's a
bummer but what are you going to do he's
a great comic i'm sure he hates me i
have no idea but i don't think
i assume everybody hates me but
he's we're not going to watch it now we
can listen to a minute no no snl will
kick off don't kill us dude
no no no no no no no no no no
we're doing a patreon yeah but it's like
personal
it ties up at the end he talks about his
drug overdose he talks about or his drug
abuse he talks about his new kid he's a
pro
comes rack around it's all clean
right not a lot of young guys are as
smooth as mullany a lot of them it's
like you know it's a mess and yeah and
he really takes pride in you know almost
like a carlin-esque uh
you know type of writing definitely
you know there's so much thought into
the writing so much thought it's
packaged perfectly it's all tight and
ties up perfectly good ending really
really incredible and then earthquake
has a new netflix it's great out here
it's great it's just classic old-school
comedy the guy's a [ __ ] vet he's been
doing the the circuit forever he had his
own club in atlanta apparently and i
messaged him and he wrote back what do
you say i just said dude this special is
incredible i'm a fan and he wrote back
that means the world of me thank you and
i shared it wow catch him on rogan i did
what'd you think great good good it's a
little long it's three hours but uh
peter isn't that isn't that all of rogue
episodes but i feel like like i got it
in two hours but yeah
great great guys just
he's like he's like us he's like [ __ ]
the industry i hate the industry they
wouldn't give me a special until
chappelle produced it you know that's
what it takes blah blah blah i mean the
guy's a [ __ ] murderer he would kill
for
for everybody like just all over the
place and uh
good friend beast yeah yeah i've heard
of a good thing it's hard for me to
watch stand up these days i feel like
you know i don't want to
hear a bit that i maybe was working on a
bit on
and you know it's now i can't touch a
whole topic i feel right i watch it but
uh
i should watch it it's fun good to watch
stand up and it's so different than than
you or me sure you're right those are
the people you want to watch the ones
who are like i'm nothing like exactly
like a family comic talking about his
kids i'm like that's questions i'll
watch like tom papa seriously because
he's exactly different you know he has a
special can you google this it's called
like
i i'm telling you again i'm telling you
for the last time or you don't know [ __ ]
something like seinfeld that's yeah
you're right you're right but it's
something it's one of his similar comics
it's older yeah
but it's incredibly good it's like the
premises he uses one premise about like
martin luther king died and his wife had
to remarry he's like how the [ __ ] do you
fill those shoes also every street you
go down it's called martial king your
kids are in school named martin luther
king it's just everywhere like you'll
never live up to it and he's like who's
the guy [ __ ] jordan's ex-wife you're
wearing his shoes you're wearing his
jersey you're going to the game oh it's
amazing
he's got great premises he has good
takes that he doesn't get his uh due for
well good for him man oh yeah it's a
tough biz yes yes he's a pro
give me that give me the name of that
damn time that's it about goddamn time
it's funny you could tell like how angry
comics are with their special
that's so true where the [ __ ] you been
my whole life
what the [ __ ] you're waiting for
[ __ ] better watch this
i remember robert schimmel had an album
title called uh if you buy this cd i can
get this car uh
marin had a couple of those too like
tickets still available the front row is
empty or whatever the [ __ ] i can't
remember but yeah marin had a few it's
just you can the bitterness is oozing
out of us of all of us yeah amazing hey
folks we might be drunk is proud to
announce our new sponsor
indochino
whether it's for a pandemic delayed
wedding or shooting a netflix special
now is the time to dress your best it's
always the right time to dress to
impress so do it in clothes that fit you
perfectly indochino makes high quality
custom fitted suits shirts and casual
wear all that surprisingly affordable
prices i went to the website i got some
pants on there i got a weird body short
legs small waist but you put all the
details in they there's no stone
unturned they think of everything and i
got the pants in the mail they fit like
a glove like a guy an old greek guy did
my tailoring you know but it was all
online it's really well done
indochino offers complete custom fitted
suits shirts casual and more at
surprisingly affordable prices every
piece is made to your exact measurement
and you can customize every detail all
on the internet choose everything about
your suit including fabric lapel
monograms statement linings you can
create a suit that fits you and your
style perfectly the best part indochino
starts at 429
for a suit that's insane the shirts are
79 with all customizations included you
get a nice suit it's going to run you
four grand
here is it that much for a nice yeah
where are you shopping you go to one of
these armani's or banana republics it
ain't cheap especially if you get it
fitted yeah that's true yeah the
tailoring is where they get you that's
how they get you
what what uh we gotta they just send us
suits it'd be nice send us some suits
we'll fight we'll wear them on an
episode you gotta get a plug there and
we'll drink we'll drink like old
fashions or some [ __ ] like don draper
will look cool [ __ ] doing this so why
don't you hook up some suits in docino
it'd be nice
this season dressed to impress on every
occasion with indochino get 50 off any
purchase at
of 399
or more by using promo code drunk at
indochino.com that's 50
off a purchase of 399 or more at
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com
promo code
drunk get on it we might be drunk is
brought to you by geology geology's
mission is to make men's skin care a
breeze
tell them about your skin and goals in a
30 second quiz and their team of
dermatologists will design a regimen
just for you that is shipped directly to
your doors that simple geology only
includes ingredients that actually make
a difference to your skin no junk no
jism
didn't say that part i improvised
uh
i've tried this it's great they sent us
some stuff uh
all kinds of you know you put it on your
face i mean look i i forget to do it
sometimes but if you have time you throw
it on you feel nice it makes you feel
dandy you've got good skin you do i yeah
you do oh thank you thank you yeah i get
a little peely but i use the uh
moisturizer fixes it right up everyday
face wash uh vital morning face cream
repairing night cream nourishing night
night cream that's you get all four of
those in the 30 days trial the easy
routine equals the results head to
geology.com
drunk to take their free skincare quiz
save up to 50
on your 30 days trial or just click the
link in the show notes that's geology g
e o l o g i e dot com slash drunk or
click the link in the show notes say 50
off your 30 day trial geology make
handsome a habit
all right we might be drunk is also
brought to you by diet smoke
edibles can hit you when you least
expect it and their dosage is uncertain
that's why we need the perfect
medium-high we hit our friends at diet
smoke for their delicious delta eight
thc gummies each gummi is infused with
10 milligrams of delta 8 thc derived
from american grown hemp delta 8 is
simply a slightly less potent thc the
diet smoke high is somewhere between the
chillness of cbd and that classic stone
feeling you get with weed plus diet
smoke comes in blue raspberry or
watermelon i literally take this every
night to sleep it's great i'm not good
on too much weed i'm a lightweight this
is the perfect amount just lulls you you
get that good eight hours where you're
out the whole night i love it it's the
perfect amount this is a genius idea
thank god somebody made this because
weed is too much thc's two i mean uh cbd
is too little this is right there in the
middle it's illegal in most states and
non-prescription just check to see if
they ship your state so when cbd isn't
enough and traditional thc is too much
enjoy the smooth buzz of diet smoke go
to dietsmoke.com
and use promo code drunk for 20 off your
order that's dietsmoke.com promo code
drunk for 20 off as a special offer
diet smokes coupon
can be used on every order diet smokes
delta 8 thc gummies are not for use or
sale to people under the age of 21
please use responsibly diet smoke isn't
light it's just right uh we might be
drunk is brought to you by lucy your
responsible consumer and you want a
responsible way to consume your nicotine
don't you if you're looking for nicotine
gum lozenges or pouches to use nicotine
to relax focus or just unwind after a
long day there's only one stop you
should make
lucy this stuff's great i haven't used
it personally but i know friends who
have used it who have a problem with uh
smoking and this has definitely helped
them out if you're looking for an
alternative to smoking why not switch
the nicotine product that can make you
feel good and you know what we all know
people have smoking problems oh yeah uh
it kills your wind it's not good for you
this is this is a good way to wean off
you know eventually hopefully you're off
this too but this is the stuff that gets
you there so if you enjoy using nicotine
you should definitely check out lucy's
products at lucy.co
that's lucy.co use promo code drunk at
checkout also i have to read this
disclaimer warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical remember if you're interested
in a better way to use nicotine visit
lucy.co and be sure to use that promo
code drunk
lucy
it's a it's a common thread with us
comics for sure i was gonna eat that oh
sorry should we do speaking of front row
empty i just read a story about billy
joel he leaves the first three rows
empty every night
why because he's sick of industry people
paying all the money and like just
sitting there with their hands folded so
he goes to the back row
and invites them up to the first row i
love the happiest people in the room i
love it what a great guy what a pro i
mean that comes from having eight
million garden shows and just
learning the lay of the lives like 30
straight nights at the garden or
something and you're like oh my god i
know it's cool these old like elton i
was in brooklyn today elton john i
looked up at the big barclays thing he's
there tonight sold out wow it's nice to
see these guys just still banging it out
and people still coming
because i think a lot of people go when
am i going to see elton john again yeah
the opening john movie is pretty cool i
loved it yeah
i mean it's how hard to make a movie
about a guy where you're like well i
mean every song is going to be a banger
yeah
you know yeah what was the other one the
queen movie
oh uh yeah i mean
yeah the guy he was at the cellar one
night really yeah he was cool what's his
name
that's it he went to college with dan st
jermaine what
yeah so he was there just like hanging
and he he came up to me after my set
because he's just there and he's he's
this is what really famous
talented people do
they're just like congrats on all your
success and i'm just like you just won
the oscar dude
come on like he's really fishing for a
compliment there wasn't that congrats on
your success i'm just like
if i'm successful what are you [ __ ]
god
what the hell just happened he played a
movie where got aids or like i got that
from a towel
no he's uh he's like a real nice guy do
you ever see any other celebs at the uh
oh they're there we just got a text from
liszt the other day joe list was like
i'm at the seller it's melanie olivia
munn conan o'brien chris rock and nick
cannon we're like ah that's fun nick
cannon's a real drama
that's true
it's a big cannonball
well conan was on snl so it's probably
supporting
he was on board on saturday exactly oh
yeah yeah that's cool yeah
melanie you see he's posted if i i'm
obsessed with fellaini but he posted a
photo about it was him uh tom hanks
conan
tina fey
uh i can't remember who else but it was
like these legends and i'm like man look
at this fun i'm hanging out with you
schlubs
you know these big they're all wearing
robes and the lighting and yeah it must
be nice i i was bored on a flight it was
like the day of the uh russian
invasion oh yeah and i was bored in a
flight and i just it's something
caroline's tweeted nick cannon dropped
in and i wrote something like how much
bad news can we get in one day
and uh that's great and and nick cannon
follows me an hour later i'm like oh
[ __ ] oh my crap that's all he can do
because he's on the mass singer so he
can't just dm me you you piece of [ __ ]
he has to just be like i saw it
that's great that's when you're that
when you have that much yeah you know he
wants to just dm me jew boy that's true
that's what he wants to write
anti-semite yeah by the way
not to get
nutty here but i heard a lot of stuff
like oh if rogan said uh juicelers he
wouldn't be working i'm like
i don't know i think the n word is worse
i think i think there's a definitely a
bigger price to pay mckenna's own show
he's doing fine yeah he got he did get
fired i heard he tried to sue
viacom for the rights to wild and out
for like 1.5 billion which i'm like you
think that show's worth more than
seinfeld
[Laughter]
and also if you're going to get
litigious
yeah who are you going to want on your
side
let's be honest that's uh can we do one
more of these and i know i'm dying i was
too scared to ask
you i'm eating nuggets i'm eating
doughnuts somebody i'm drinking this is
not a healthy afternoon no no though is
it ever we come we're on the road we're
not healthy then we come back and this
is our [ __ ] life you got that right
you guys i hope you i hope the listeners
appreciate that we're going to die at
60. for you guys
um we got to get bert kreischer on here
just so we have his last record
what um wait what we got to do news too
oh let's do some news stories sure hell
yeah
let's see
baby
it's gonna be hard to beat last week's
uh victoria's secret model and whatnot
okay here we go here we go
who's reading first condoms approved for
anal sex come in 54 different sizes
yikes that's a lot of sizes
one for each gender
did you know there were more than two
sizes black
and everybody else these anal sex
condoms
measuring kit printed does that mean
you're at the store and you're like does
that mean you're at the store and you're
like can i get some condoms and they're
like no no butt condoms
is that what you're doing i guess yeah
at cvs or selling these they probably
have to be stronger because the anal
yeah you know it's a different thing
now how does this work do i put this up
my ass or what is this what's going on
here peter's actually printed out this
[ __ ] that's why he's uh he's the king
who's making it to g
i think beer jew might have
you got to be doing all right downtown
huh
oh
i've never had anal sex honestly what i
don't like i've tried i'm like i'm not
into it they don't seem like they're
gonna like it they seem like it's gonna
you know what it is it's like i know the
vagina is gonna be good it's kind of
like am i gonna just watch the sopranos
again or do i need to watch a new show
that i know is gonna be a mess it's a
good pro wow right yeah some shitty show
that she's not gonna like
that's a good point look anal's not that
bad it hurts for an hour
[Laughter]
wait a minute matt you've got your cliff
find your width wrap the measuring tool
gently around the middle of your
erection all right before by the way
mark saw this before and he goes what
are we i'm like we're not whipping it
out oh okay
that's for the patreon you gotta pay if
i get hard though i'm [ __ ] that donut
[Laughter]
you're gonna give it everything but
semen
[Laughter]
not till i'm done with it this is
hilarious okay so you put this at the
base
i'd say i'm probably at the maybe the d
or z
but you're all girth i'm girthy and no
length i'm all length and no girl i've
got some length but i'm but i'm girthier
i was hoping you had no legs no no i got
length but all right girthy i'm a girthy
man ron white has a hilarious joke about
him his stick being girthy and not long
and he goes it's more like a cheese
wheel
that's amazing
but i will stretch the size oh wow with
a cigar that's a great
it's a great this is so funny like how
just official this is yeah
women are so nice because uh i heard a
guy be like i was like you packing he's
like i've never gotten any complaints
i'm like well what woman is gonna be
like
hold on i got a few complaints
let me fill out the comment card
[Laughter]
like you're gonna whip it out and a
woman's like oh
i know oh they're nice
one star
yeah yeah exactly
all right i don't know this is a lot of
a lot of work here without whipping it
out i can't tell what's what
my uh my my lady was like uh
we were got drunk one night when we
first started dating she was like i love
[ __ ] i feel like our parts match she
was like my last boyfriend was his dick
was too wide and i was like all right i
gotta get up
it's kind of nice to hear because you're
like okay you don't like a wide dick i
don't have a wide dick but also like
saying i prefer to watch movies at home
yeah
yeah exactly so
yeah what's that i have a deeper vagina
yeah she's telling you that's what she's
telling me and
vagina sizes vary we don't we all talk
about dick size all day size queen this
and that but the vagina is a different
thing on every lady it is
have you ever had because i'm not big
i wouldn't say i'm small but i'm not big
but i've had girls like whoa whoa easy
slow down hold on it's good to hear that
it feels great to hear that but i'm like
what do you do with a guy packing heat i
think they avoid them aha
but how do you avoid i don't know
because you see girls on dating you see
girls on like dating naps and you're
like don't if you're like under eight
inches don't even apply and then but
like you never see women like small
dicks only that's true you never see
that [ __ ] like i don't know if i'm
supposed to say this but schumer would
always be like i hate a big dick they
hurt they're not fun like it's for men
mostly
is it i mean i feel like it's mostly to
be like hey guys i have a you tell your
guy friends women i feel like i mean
some women i think some women care but i
think for the most part it's like dudes
okay because you hear these eight inch
girls on the uh the internet and you're
like oh [ __ ] that's how all women are
yeah you know i don't i don't think so
all right all right i mean i could be
wrong we might be getting torn apart in
the comments right now like an
eight-inch dick would tear you apart
ladies
[Laughter]
wait wait what's another news story
michelangelo that's a tiny dick
but he had a good body mm-hmm
they made up for they it's like he knew
right
it does suck women have to see it they
don't they don't only see it till it
comes out they have no real idea
i mean i remember the old to tell joke
he's like the first time you want to be
magical you know when you press it up
against the bus window
bus window is so much better than you
know department store window
sean patton has a funny joke where he's
like you can kind of tell a guy's dick
by how the guy is shaped if a guy's
short and fat he's probably got a short
wide dick if he's tall and thin he's got
a long skinny dick but every now and
then you meet a guy who's who walks like
this
that's the curvy dick that's great
that's a funny pattern bit all right
what do you got on the next one sally
you want to read that yeah so your
modeling agent accused of recruiting
young girls for jeffrey epstein sex
trafficking ring was found dead by
hanging in a cell interesting we got a
pattern here hmm
his name is jean-luc brunell
yeah 75
had been under investigation for the
rape and sex trafficking of minors
he's being held at some so-and-so prison
following his arrest in 2020 so he
suicided himself or he was suicided yeah
right so john luke
that's you it makes you think of
jean-luc picard from star trek although
this guy was also in the next generation
the younger generation
deep space nine-year-old
everybody there it is
that's a keeper you're all right you're
all right put that online
yeah this guy deep space nine-year-olds
to boldly go or no one is
definitely i mean do you think i mean
there's people who always like into the
conspiracy where like of course he he
was murdered but also it's like
this is probably when you want to punch
your ticket right you're 75 right this
is a probably a low point yes it's
believable that this is suicide is all
i'm saying right right right definitely
yeah you're in prison at 75 but why
can't we just go the guy killed himself
oh because of epstein
ties right isn't that yeah the
skepticism i mean so wouldn't jaslane
have killed herself too or had been
murdered too or maybe they're facing it
out if they're really doing
it you can experience left around too
long she would have sung i mean if she
wanted to sing she would have sung by
now i think she's safe it's funny that
we use the word to sing to like it's
like singing is nice but it's also i
guess to describe people who are on
epstein's island yeah yeah
mafia said he sang like a canary yeah
do you want to sing yeah
yeah that'd be funny if american idol
was just people confessing
the whole show simon's like you're
terrible
i was never on that island right right
by the way when i went to st thomas we
took a boat like a catamaran around and
we saw epstein's island no pretty cool
yeah had the helipad it was pretty cool
it was beautiful
i'll tell you this though the lady was
doing the tour and she's like this is
whatever that was taken over by columbus
in 1401 whatever that this epson island
everybody went to the edge of the boat
like whoa picture picture it was it was
the highlight of the trip damn yeah but
you just picture everybody getting off
well well they got off yeah yeah you
know they had a little dock it was
beautiful like big homes and it was
pretty like boats everywhere and he
bought the island next door so he didn't
have neighbors i mean the guy was always
yeah yeah
you know that guy's packing money or
it's like
buying the apartment next door would be
right right go get the whole island [ __ ]
it i don't want to so i said hey how
much was how much does an island go for
and she went when he bought it was eight
mil i was like eight million it's like
steinbrenner buying the yankees for when
he bought them exactly
eight mills apartments or 14 mil in the
village you know but it's just a piece
of dirt you know wow it doesn't have
plumbing it doesn't have electricity
plumbing he had all that yeah no i'm
talking about the one he bought that
when you buy it
it's just a piece of dirt right right
right but i think it was habitated
yeah that's nothing to him
pocket change
crazy but yeah look at that okay the
94th academy awards the oscars are on
right now
the episode
oh oops
uh the ballots are printed out
make your selections and discuss the
nominees
oh
okay
by the way you've got peters you're a
[ __ ] you're a mensch you're
incredible all right so we start with
actor in a leading role by the way can i
say this real quick it really bugs me
i think they cut i don't know if it's
editing but it's definitely air makeup
editing and sound engineering sound
sound not sound engineering score sound
score yeah i love score is like okay i
know a lot of you listening know who
like hans zimmer danny elfman all these
amazing john williams john williams like
music is such an important part of
movies totally it's it's it's about
editing it is movie making it's editing
it's huge editing's huge it's it's just
complete disrespect i think we just want
to see celebrity faces and that's it
they're like cut out the [ __ ] are we
done with celebrities no that's i think
what they think is all like that's who's
what we're tuning in for
i mean complete disrespect completely
it's about the art of the movie making
about filmmaking and then we're just oh
oh jennifer lawrence is there who gives
a [ __ ] all right what do we got all
right i haven't seen all these but actor
in the leading role is javier bardem for
being the ricardo's benedict cumberbatch
the power of the dog that was great yeah
he's amazing although do you hear sam
elliott talking some [ __ ] no he said it
he
called it a piece of [ __ ] on marin's
podcast and was like who is she to make
this movie you know in new zealand like
what does she know about like ranches
and you're like maybe he watches that
[ __ ] the way doctors watch er
like i don't know what the problem but
also
yeah you're allowed to make [ __ ] that
you haven't experienced of course movies
like yeah
yeah star trek lord of the rings it's
all made up like
what do you know about space you weren't
an astronaut i know i'm a [ __ ]
director i know that's crazy it's crazy
get out of here sam ellie but i bet he
sound cool when he shits on you oh yeah
he's got that what do you know about
movie making he's so chill in lebowski
why couldn't he be more like that i know
right andrew garfield tick tick boom
will smith king richard denzel macbeth
all right so i
i
i've seen them all except for king
richard i turned off being the regardos
because it was a [ __ ] turd really
yeah uh i heard it wasn't funny at all
it's like
i love nicole kim and she's gorgeous but
like she's had a lot of work done and
you're playing the most expressive comic
actress of all time good point on top of
that
i mean she's an amazing actress but then
you got uh
[ __ ]
this woke nonsense that aaron sorkin has
to push in there's a scene where one of
the writers for the show like tells the
showrunner basically to shut up and i'm
like yeah i bet a woman writer in the
50s yeah yeah to a male show runner i
know keep it realistic that's all i'm
saying like that's great if you want to
make a show like that now sure but like
right if you're trying to make this
believable yeah and i know uh marvelous
mrs measles is a great show i've watched
a couple episodes it's very good but i
watch a trailer and she does like a
[ __ ] mic drop i was like this isn't
something people in the 50s did no i
hate mic drop yeah stop adding modern
[ __ ] yeah
so who do you go with uh guys for actor
are we doing all these
i don't know we don't have to do all of
them let's do the top three let's just
leave out the ones we just made fun of
them
all right who do you got for actor
[ __ ] this is tough hard not to go denzel
man well yeah yeah
i thought i i like andrew garfield's
amazing tick tick boom he's he is
incredible in that uh was he
yeah it's hard he's kind of like
one of those chosen hollywood guys where
he's he just gets those meaty parts and
he's so good yeah does denzel have a he
has one for training day
yeah but he's denzel i know but i feel
like if you have one already
you have a less likely chance of getting
another that's true yeah i mean it could
be cumberbatch or i mean did will smith
ever win one i don't think i think he
went for ollie
or one for best picture one of the two i
think he went like a golden globe he
[ __ ] sucked yeah it wasn't great he
was good but the movie sucked someone
break this down so i think uh there is a
black
vote as a constituency of of black
people in the academy and their vote
will be split between will smith and
denzel washington they'll be hard to
choose so i'm gonna go with andrew
garfield for the gay vote even though
he's not gay it's sort of a gay issue
he's a cute boy he's a musical he's
amazing yeah i watched a little bit of
it very good it's good dude so i'm gonna
pick andrew garfield
all right actor
i like that that's possible yeah i mean
i don't know my only issue now that i
say denzel the only issue is that like
who the [ __ ] did they even i wonder how
many of them even watch macbeth exactly
but you get some some cool guy points
for watching macbeth you do yeah you
know like i felt pretty good about
myself after i walked out i was like
yeah i saw a shakespearean movie
2022. i was bored out of my mind but i
watched
it was very dense but there was some
violence i only tick-tock for an hour
so who are you going
uh
i haven't seen i've only seen about half
of these but i'm gonna go with
i'm going cumber he's good all right
supporting we got
claron he hind from belfast which i i'm
dying to see i hear is great uh
trey katzer coda troy
oh troy sorry trevor jesse plemmons
power of the dog jk simmons being the
ricardo's
cody smith mcphee power the dog he's
great who's that he's the the young
skinny
guy
oh the the kid the
he's got a shot
okay i want to tell you why i'm an idiot
uh in 2002 will smith went up against
denzel washington will smith for ali and
denzel watching for training day yeah
denzel won yeah so the black vote thing
is probably not smart that wasn't okay
but it's a different time that's true
it's 20 years ago well also
i mean training day is a way better
movie than ali i agree it's just way
better
but and also denzel was it was one of
those like we owe you one yes
he should have won for the hurricane but
he lost and then yeah i think he went
for glory as his best supporters
supporting's different different yeah
yeah so he has two he has two but it's
it's like uh
you know pacino they gave him that scent
of a woman oscar where it's like
they departed this is [ __ ] exactly
scorsese it's like
you know not his best but they we owe
you one which i hate how they do that
because you're like it should be the
movie yeah not this like revenant's not
leo's best exactly exactly wolf of wall
street is awesome in them amazing but
there are makeup calls in basketball
like i always called that and like now
we're gonna give it to you on the back
end in the last two minutes interesting
he's right interesting it's part of the
game be nice if girlfriends did that you
know like i i steamrolled you on all
those arguments but
i owe you one there's a blowy yeah
you're like
you [ __ ] that
palm springs oh yeah one i say the other
way hey honey you [ __ ] up the other
day how about a blowy
[Laughter]
there you go all right chloe sounds
nicer actress in the leading role
jessica chastain i've never even heard
of this movie the eyes of camilla
she is hot dude that movie uh that
sworkit movie she's hot as helen
olivia coleman the last daughter didn't
i love her i never saw that zombie
cruise parallel mother it's amazing yeah
parallel mothers penelope crew is
supposed to be great i think that's
that's elmo davar uh nicole kim and
being the ricardo's christian sewage
spencer jesus i got no idea for this one
because they're all great yeah they're
all great actors right who knows about
the movie yeah
you only you only saw nicole right
you saw daughter mm-hmm
i don't know about this one
i'm gonna go chastain because she's
playing tammy faye and they always love
when they do a uh biopic and they get
real crazy so i'm gonna just want to
bang to chest sure sure but uh i mean i
wouldn't mind banging cruz and stuart
either but i'm just saying i'm going i'm
going tammy faye
actress in the supporting oh
sorry southeast what do you got
that's toss-up i don't know yeah i don't
even know i only saw one of them
according to hail mary yeah i haven't
seen that i mean and now i'm still worth
the point where i haven't seen these i
mean are we giving up yeah did we just
do the two male categories
[Laughter]
uh probably kirsten dunst i haven't seen
the
but she's great in power with the dog
oh oh is she on there yeah oh you're
talking about uh supporting somebody i
don't know about any of these i don't i
yeah i heard king richard's amazing i
haven't seen i want to see it it was fun
judy dench though is a
is a um a dame would you yeah yeah out
of respect
you know what's a good flick with her do
you ever see notes on a scandal no kate
blanchette super hot in that movie notes
on a scam not a teacher who [ __ ] her
student oh it's pretty good
you know what's
hot is uh
oh is it tilde we're gonna call this
episode mark with bang judy dan
is that the name of this i would knight
her with my dick
sure why not
i could hear some stories about summer
stock and shakespeare park let's move up
the best picture all right because i
mean we're just or should we do i mean
we're not we don't have time to do all
this [ __ ] no this is 18 categories here
it's longer than the [ __ ] actual
oscars
all right best picture belfast coda
don't look up drive my car which i hear
is great haven't seen that dune
hated that hated dude but that's not my
cup turd all right there's someone to do
not into sci-fi no i'm not into boring
ass [ __ ] movies right uh king richard
licorice pizza
nightmare alley
power the dog west side story which i
also heard was good i've been so many
what it used to be five they do well
there's too many movies now they do ten
ah okay
uh i'm gonna go best picture
belfast it's artsy fartsy have you seen
it no you should just go off of that all
right power the dog is a female director
that was and it was good too so that's
got a shot
that might win director
that's true west side story has been
done already they should make sam
elliott have to present it
west side story won best picture
when it came out originally everyone
says it's an incredible one i want to
see it again bombed at the box office
but it looks there was one like a two
minute frame they played of it and i was
like this is insanely
well done like the spielberg is a genius
you know he's great
but uh i didn't see licorice pizza i
didn't see pta
yeah do you like it i didn't see it but
loved it you loved it i heard mixed mix
too that's what i heard too
um i would like to drive my car yeah
there's a short story it's based on by
murakami it's incredible oh yeah it's
very very good and i heard uh
i heard nightmare alley's cool it's cool
you saw it yeah it's cool
theater it's it's dark and gloomy and uh
and the cast is good and caitlyn chet is
[ __ ] hot she is hot
okay
it's good i'm going belfast
yeah i was i could see that or power the
dog they always go with something rc
fartsy yeah
it's gonna it's gonna be one of those
you don't think it's don't look up
because people like don't look up too
divisive ah
i didn't love yeah you lose the
republican vote basically
is that a big vote at the oscars
those two guys
is anyone winning the awards and going
hey i think january 6 was cool
[Laughter]
is anyone going i think women should not
be allowed to get an abortion
that's my acceptance speech that's where
you get an abortion in texas nightmare
alley
what uh what else we got but wait a
minute okay okay yeah yeah all right i'm
saying belfast you're saying
power the dog
i'll say power the dog just to mix it
just i like power the dog i thought it
was good i loved it cues i'll say king
richard not a goody movie year though
still yeah not really no nothing
exciting nothing blue a lot of people
were mad that spider-man wasn't
nominated people loved that movie the
new one oh with tom holland it's all
three of them oh i didn't see it people
[ __ ] loved that movie dude people
love it
you know what's going to be crazy in
like two years i bet
these marvel movies will be in the
oscars just to get views up oh yeah
that's a theory okay
right now tom holland to post an
instagram story their viewers shoot
right the [ __ ] up exactly we have the
control now not us but them
what is coda c-o-d-a isn't it musical
uh-oh
peter's posted a story here i'm kind of
interested in who did
uh our your producer matt peters uh oh
smallest apartment in new york city says
it's 60 square feet this is officially
oh i love this guy
in all of new york city
this guy's 6'4
go go ahead shoot ahead because i i
watch the beginning of this and it takes
forever
he's looking at other apartments yeah
it's 60 feet
i don't i don't know the neighborhood
but it's 60 feet
and it's like
you know what though and if you and if
you're there with a girlfriend it's
negative 30 feet
it just kills you right uh what uh what
do you think this would cost you
how much do you think this would cost
well it depends on the neighborhood for
a thousand dollars for this [ __ ] well
yeah what's the neighborhood they're
going a thousand easy you think so oh
yeah
if it's manhattan a thousand for sure
yep
yeah
it is yeah that's a good point you know
1100 and you got it's
[ __ ] man oh it's a loft it goes up yeah
but you can barely fit dude there's no
ladder right you got to install a ladder
it can only hold like 235 so don't don't
think about bringing a lady up there
yeah
technically an outdoor space all right
this looks like lower east side it does
a good point
out here he's got a fire escape garden
come on inside you are paying for the
neighborhood we're on a beautiful
tree-lined street in west village west
village oh jg melons that's right by the
cellar dude that's mcdougall and bleaker
i know that uh corner
you know what though if you're a kid if
you're young this is not bad not bad i
would do it
oh 14 saint marks i would do i would do
it for the location if i was if i was
young why not hell yeah
oh this is it this is it man what
well same layout basically
new yorkers are mentally ill
i think this is imagine watching this
being from like indianapolis i mean like
are you out of your [ __ ] mind oh yeah
that's how bad
i know
dude it's crazy and it's also but you
know what the only like real deal
breakers for me
in new york are the ones where it's like
the shared bathroom i did that you did a
shared bathroom i did it for a year i
went nuts i almost did it but then i was
like give me a [ __ ] another roommate
i was i couldn't do it were you living
alone or no i was but it kills your soul
it's just a room like that and then a
shared bathroom and it's you and a bunch
of weirdos and old people and you see
everybody naked it's horrifying yeah the
shared bathroom for me would have that's
you just you don't want to knock on the
door for your bathroom at home and hear
an unfamiliar video yes that's tough and
bringing your [ __ ] every time to the
battle you got the bag of soap shampoo
sponge or a forever road gig yes exactly
you feel like an idiot eleven hundred
dollars there you go yeah we called it
it's it makes sense right west village
you said lower east side i would have
gone higher i think in the western
village
west village is dicey now i live in the
village and it's it's not right
a lot a lot of homeless guys will just
walk up to you and just stop and like
stare you down you're like what is this
grand theft auto i know what's about to
happen to me
it's bad there's that guy on the
wheelchair he like torments you
i was doing pull-ups the other day like
a psycho and this homeless guy just
waiting
and i was like trying to work in a rep
he was waiting for mark to get tired so
we can mug him exactly he's like i'm
gonna get him when he when he's done and
then i got all you know you're out of
breath and he's like all right can i get
some money and i was like
this next was this says the next
building was converted floors to get
double the units on a one one floor
ceiling heights were 4.5 feet
that's that's not a i mean that's
someone who's 6'3 that's [ __ ] insane
i would be in constant pain you can
really just go into sleep that's what it
is that's it yeah yeah we gotta get brad
williams in there
what's that you just crawl in yeah yeah
you got an army crawl that's a nightmare
that's that's gonna [ __ ] your body up
yeah the only good thing about that
apartment is you tell a girl that you're
like yeah you're at a bar with a girl
you're like my apartment ceilings are
four foot five she's like that's that's
a lie what what are the other stories oh
sure there was over there arthur the pbs
show
arthur ended his 25 season run on pbs
this year it started in 1996 with
celebrity guest voices making cameos
throughout the run such as joan rivers
bj novak matt damon what is arthur that
show he's doing
he's an aardvark
show always bugged me because
i every time i'd be on the road in a
hotel and i'd be flipping i'd be like
arthur's on i think it was a dudley
moore movie
a children's cartoon so i always was
like ugh
[Laughter]
you're like where the [ __ ] the drunk
guy that's what i prefer i love that
movie has simpsons beat it yeah right a
lot yeah oh yeah it started in 90. since
that's already 30 years wow simpson's
like 34. is it still on 1990 yeah yeah
oh my god it's incredible what a run
the last one like every major event in
world history yeah right
it's genius i mean genius
simpsons is genius because it
dumb people like it and smart people
like it yeah it hits every
brain type yeah it's got jokes they go
over people's heads but then it's got
the silly stuff too it's it's almost
like dave attell
yeah
futurama's back now
oh really there you go that was a good
one yeah only smart people like that
show well because that's that's the most
educated writing staff like in all of
writing dumb history they have like
whatever like 12 masters like really
eight doctorates between them
they're like the most overeducated
comedy writing staff wait there's one
more man
oh wow that's cool
uh what is that took
at uk
a movie never made because the lead
actor keeps dying originally after john
belushi then sam kinnison then john
candy then chris farley whoa
uh i heard the new guy in talks with
john luke brunel so
i was gonna say they should hire cosby
that'll be a nice way to get him out of
there that's the story of an eskomo
moving to new york city it may never be
made i remember reading about this
actually
in kennison's book yeah and phil hartman
was attached holy [ __ ] this movie's
cursed damn i'd like to see some of
these uh
dailies of these guys just seeing
kinison and belushi and and farley well
was that ever even i don't know i don't
think they think they're shooting
oh i think these guys were just attached
i don't think it gotcha cause i remember
kennison i
i think he turned it down though i think
there was some weird thing he was like
attached and then he turned it down damn
that's wild cause i just remembered this
now but it was like i think he was kind
of like how this movie is gonna suck or
something like i could be totally wrong
but the curse of eight tuck yeah don't
take this movie what would you got any
peeves you guys oh i got peeves i gotta
pee hit me i'm gonna look mine up the
mugs that keep your coffee hot yeah
travel mug travel mug it like keeps it
too hot it never cools down
i i hate to take the top off
i'm not smart
which i'll never say to you why don't
you take your top off
oh was it the coaster yeah all right
what's your pivot um
yeah i don't don't love a hot too hot
coffee you're like i just need this
chemical in my body this caffeine let's
go i love it to be hot though
when you put some milk in there milk
helps
i'm solving this peeve right here yeah
women hate when you solve sam you got to
listen
all right
i got two peeves
i hate the guy who interrupts uh i'm
sorry what ah well that my realtor does
this yeah we'll be looking at apartments
and the they'll be like a nice lady
trying to show the apartment and he has
to get his chime in [ __ ] and she
goes
okay so the wall these are load-bearing
wall you're like oh very well and he
gets louder to cut her off and that's a
huge peeve you're getting it'll be a
real load baron watch it
stops all right yeah but i hate when
like they're both like they're now
butting heads with a with a with a
trying to get a word in and then he gets
really loud and she's like okay fine you
go and he's like blah blah blah blah all
right we got it and i'm like i feel bad
for these people because they're just
trying to tell me about the apartment
which i want to hear and then he chimes
in and has to get louder which makes me
nuts women really hate dudes like this
yes right
there's like courses on women being like
don't be a victim to like guys like
cutting you off totally
you know uh
what does it say about a guy's
personality he's insecure and he's like
i gotta i gotta show you i'm working
here you know it's like those guys like
we should have a meeting and you're like
oh you just want to feel like you have a
job you don't really we don't need a
meeting there's no meeting we just need
to feel important
so i have and the other day i was like
hey she was talking and uh he was like
oh geez and i'm like well she's in the
middle of a [ __ ] sentence and you cut
her off and then she tries to cut back
and they got way louder and it drives me
crazy yeah it makes you it makes you
nervous when it's like because it's like
an extension of you
so it's like this guy's being rude and i
feel uncomfortable exactly it's like
he's like representing me yes and i
don't like my dad does it to my mom and
that always bothered me one time my mom
pulled me to the side and i she was like
i appreciate how you
stopped your dad that one time and i was
like oh yeah yeah that's how stepmom
porn start
thanks for doing that hey it's no big
deal let me make it up to you i'll suck
your i'll suck your dick yes
that's night of my life
this [ __ ] has really jumped the [ __ ]
what's that you have another piece i do
this this thing where everybody has to
do everything together you know like
you know they go up we have five people
on this podcast no no not like that but
like know i'm out of the bar with a
couple of guys and i'm like oh i'm gonna
i gotta make a phone call like wait i'm
about to make a phone call let's do you
we do the phone call together you go
over there i'll go over there i'm like
i'm just gonna make a phone call like
what are we doing here yeah but i think
they're like don't leave or whatever i
don't know what it is but they're like
oh i'm making a phone call anyway or
like oh you're leaving i'll go with you
and i'm like well you're leaving 30
minutes after me i hate we got to do
everything together yeah oh you're
getting food i'll get food
all right and then i go get food like
wait can you wait for me i'm like come
on oh the the planner person who like
wants to come along and then [ __ ]
derail a plan exactly unreal we got to
do everything together well that drives
me nuts when i was like why the thing i
wanted to do and now you're like wait up
right and i'm changing the plan you're a
hijacker hi jeff you're no different
than the [ __ ] terrorists that we try
to keep out of this country day to day
my friend here here
also a good name for a hand job on
edible hijacker but all right somebody
tweet that
so those are my peeves you gotta peeve
uh i have a few one is definitely two
one is definitely when people uh okay so
here's one
you're the airport they have those
narrow stalls some airports they only
have narrow stalls and you don't think
about it until you're in a regularly
sized stall guess what i'm at the
airport i got a backpack i got a rolly
bag and i got a winter coat you think i
want to jam all that [ __ ] into a door
that won't open what is this i'm
[ __ ] with bags on top of me i'm good
it's like an avalanche in here i'm dying
yeah no that's annoying give me a real
[ __ ] stall i know what is this rikers
what the hell so that's one let's see
what else i got and everybody at the
airport has luggage oh it makes no sense
to me and you can't put the luggage
outside somebody will run off with it
500 bag like that exactly
i got two of me i gotta pee for you
people who say like not your i passed a
sign on the way here it said not your
grandma's brussels uh spice brussel
burrito i'm like not my gra
my grandma's never made me a burrito
i don't know what you're talking about
you're not your grandmas i'm like what
do you who is this for yeah did anyone
even if you are mexican was like did you
grow up on brussels sprout burritos
is that part of their like who the hell
is that so [ __ ] like that where i'm like
i don't know what the hell this ad means
yeah none of it makes sense none of it
adds up no everything about this ad is
wrong throw an abuela by the way
a woman yeah
but then brussels you know that doesn't
uh maybe they're trying to be funny
maybe they know that's ridiculous
maybe that's what didn't work no we're
professionals it didn't work for us
ain't gonna work for the general public
here here i'm coming in i'm taking your
advertising team by storm your [ __ ]
garbage you hear me i don't know what
company it was i'm calling out right now
but yeah if you search not your
grandma's brussels uh burrito i'm sure
you'll find it also
not to be a [ __ ] but
i would want my grandmother's brussel
burrito you know i'd be like oh [ __ ] i
was hoping you'd have my same
grandmother's
she made a great brussels burrito yeah
what the [ __ ] are you saying about my
grandma exactly she could crack a
[ __ ]
pretty simple burrito yeah wouldn't that
be a better restaurant we make [ __ ] just
like you ghost tauros yeah spice
brussels hey not your grandmas hey dos
tauros you're on notice yes you just
made the list my friend they make a
decent burrito no they're very good i
prefer
[Laughter]
my abuela yes abuela
all right what is tia is that ant auntie
yeah tia yeah yeah and then miho is my
son son yeah okay it might be my boy i'm
not sure but it's your son yeah it's
just my eco is boy right
yeah yeah
and what did you say miho miho i think
that's short for my boy
semi-topical so i wonder by the time
this comes out it's not going to be
relevant but there was a thing about
sean penn in ukraine oh yeah and his
whole thing about you know he's in
ukraine
and i was like what the hell's this guy
doing then i looked it up he's recently
divorced i was like that explains that
anyone who just got out of something
you're just like how much worse can a
war zone really be and then you're like
that should i really that should be the
whole front lines of the military it's
just dudes who just got out of something
oh that's because they're because
they're they're literally on the front
lines like if i die she's gonna be so
upset like do you know how sad she's
gonna be right if i get murdered right
now they're literally dudes that are
like fine with death that's great and
every guy they kill they're like cheryl
we're fighting for the ukrainians like
i'm fighting against that alimony
you lied to me
oh [ __ ] sorry
birth control
there's something there right i like
that i like i'll give it a go you were
right i might have already posted by the
time this comes out yeah it's topical it
fits two definitions of dead man walking
oh
well done although no one knows that
[ __ ] movie but us
susan sarandon you're right she's a
looking woman
oh yeah oh yeah getting pulled up her in
uh the rocky horror yeah man and a man
on death row really seems a good
you got that right
is this anything
okay
my lady is on tick tock seven hours of
the day and it drives me nuts but
you know
there you go yamaha yikes it's friday
she still looks good she's got some
bombs huh yeah dude holy hell yeah like
we're ukraine yeah oh look at that jeez
he's baking bread in that dress
um
but yeah so ladies on tick-tock seven
hours a day but you know men are always
sitting around like i don't understand
women i don't know i don't know women
whatever what do women want i feel like
the algorithm figured that [ __ ] out in
like an hour so like men are sitting
around like we don't know our
girlfriends what do they want
the algorithm no she's getting all these
targeted ads it's all [ __ ] that i'm like
i should have thought of that
it's almost like she has a gay friend
who's i want to get her phone and i'll
i'll know what kind of makeup she likes
i'll know what music she likes i'll know
what dresses she likes i'll know
everything so if i take the phone i'll
be the best boyfriend ever it's also
funny that like even if you learned all
this [ __ ] you probably wouldn't do it
yeah what am i gonna learn to dance and
do it for like that's true if you guys
swapped phones she could see your
pornhub algo and you could see her
chopping algo that's pretty good that
was very good it's pretty good that's
very good but it's like a gay friend
because it knows the makeup the
difference is if if he if he gets her
phone he's gonna get the stuff or if she
sees his phone she's gonna be like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you oh yeah good
point you want me to be a little boy
and filipino
[Laughter]
go prepare
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
but yeah yeah the algo knows her so well
and more than i do i don't know about
her makeup but the alcohol knows the
makeup sure so i'm just try there's
something there i feel like about how it
knows her more than i know her and i
should tap into it but guess what you
could never get you can't get a woman
makeup
no you can't be like the algorithm can
be like the algorithm would say [ __ ] you
could never say exactly yeah i was like
you should try this makeup you're like
you're like you should try this makeup
it's like look i know i gave you a black
eye but either way
maybe that's the angle though maybe it's
the algorithm sasha you can't sure you
know the algo's like have you thought
about planet fitness
by the way that was a joke for anyone
who just tuned in for this episode and
doesn't understand comedy because we're
getting more and more of those really
you ever post a joke oh my god i posted
one about nato the other day
and a guy's like nato's no joke and i
was like nothing's a joke right we make
videos making a joke this is a comedy
account [ __ ] i hate that [ __ ]
that drives me crazy
racism isn't funny i know we'll tell
that to chris rock dave chappelle
richard pryor you make it funny you're
making a joke
yeah
i feel like i lost you there no you
didn't lose oh okay i wish you gave a
white guy in the example too i wish you
said george carlin too
okay what are you saying that they're
playing on racial justice no no i know
but if they throw it in because we're
you know we're we're talking about our
bits i thought yeah i was hoping you
threw a white guy in there as well louie
has that great bit about uh black people
don't [ __ ] with time machines you know
nothing before 1980 thank you you know
great white guy would be like i'll take
the year one we have a table right here
for you sir great great [ __ ] great but
that's a bit about racism yeah nothing's
funny nothing is nothing's nothing's
born funny
right you know you're making fun of fat
stuff being fat people are funny like
yes have you seen panette have you seen
louie anderson they make fun of being
fat it's funny i haven't seen them
recently i heard they don't look well
recently yeah they're both not doing
great but great great comics oh yeah
killer uh killed no you got something
there for sure all right all right i'll
play with i think that might be the
angle though they can say it i can't
yeah because i'm doing on stage i can
feel them like ah but it's not clicking
no so i need the click and that might be
the click only he had the [ __ ] gave
him the attention span to tick tock
because that's
i get stuck on there sometimes how you
doing with your new algo on tick tock i
remember you said you i'm killing i'm
killing finally good for you yeah so i
had these young guys uh joey avery and
daud
in sacramento and they were like they're
young guys they're all about content
they know about the algo and all that
and they're like
this is embarrassing you're tick tock
like for where you're at this is this is
sad i was like yeah you're right what
should i do and they go honestly i would
delete this all and start again and once
i did that it just shot up
so thank you guys
funny guys check them out
well uh should we plug dates or what
yeah yeah you got that long enough oh
this is an hour too long
too long
not really
but we got a lot of fun guests coming up
march 31st rochester rochester this
weekend
um i hope beacon will be sold out i
think it will be it'll be so bad yeah
it's only singles left right now we're
taping this thing
get those in cells
break california
uh salt lake city april 15th and 16th oh
yeah great club uh [ __ ] yeah i'm sorry
my eyes are shoving oh my god um
albany toronto second show added
brothers there you go uh
east providence rhode island tampa
cleveland
houston
dania beach buffalo san jose
sucky sucky yeah i don't know what i'm
talking about a long time no
cover mark well you've got to promote
the tour love it look at that we're
doing some theaters we're all over the
place all over the road uh scoot it up
to march oh wow they got my website
fixed
hallelujah
i can't read anything i got it i got you
beard you got that or sally you got that
march 30th at new york city march 31st
dania beach yeah in april dania beach
still danny b straight to our april 2nd
april 7th here in indianapolis yeah
helium uh that's all weekend there april
14th
charlottesville virginia at the southern
it's a little theater then on to durham
north carolina washington dc austin
texas april 20th yeah the paramount
theater doing anything else down there
moon tower festival so it's a fun time i
try to do segura's pot if i can and
straight down to phoenix for four nights
house of comedy maybe i've never heard
of calusa calusa casino that should be
tough i'm gonna get my ass kicked
california it's mid california so it's
going to be rough [ __ ]
ranchers yeah exactly ranchers farmers
and meth heads and mid mayor and addison
addison improv san jose improv that's a
big one i'm there too it's bigger
chicago cleveland irvine you're cleaning
up here all right there you go irvine
huntsville cleveland chicago at the vic
come on out should be fun
uh dc lincoln theater that's where
chappelle shot killed him softly
uh fun photo looks good
didn't take it
and uh
yeah yeah we're cooking folks the pod is
growing we got some big guests cooking
um that's a mindy tucker photo shout out
minnie tucker
oh yeah some videos
uh all right so yeah we love you guys uh
we might be drunkpod.com if you want
merch you can have a glass like this or
uh yeah
whatever the [ __ ] you want the
patreon.com we might be drunk pod
uh i mean [ __ ] sally beard you anything
to plug
if you sign up to the highest patreon
level the beard jewel come to your house
and make you drink it go down on you
all right you're getting all these
ladies like he's so hot blah blah blah
his dick's proportional
that's going to start today
[Laughter]
i'm not working a new spot right now if
anyone was coming by it's two blocks
from here it's called say less say less
that's a great title
for a special it's like uh you know it's
kind of like tao like that's what i say
on most first dates
sam's back
i don't know where i went i'm back but
sorry i'm cutting you off here say less
you're there
you're slinging drinks
cockologist he makes the best drink in
the biz check him out
this is a great whiskey riff i think we
might have a new one put the ingredients
on the screen
sally you got anything to plug pay less
buy shoes there there you go
great shoes solid i used to go there as
a kid
holy [ __ ]
uh all right well you gotta you wanna
you gotta
sally's done some sketches you get
you're on youtube you're on something
yeah check out your webs you got a
website yeah salacuse.com
okay that's my photos and skits
s-a-l-a-c-u-s-e
we need a song like this to lead in can
we can we get a jazz riff to please
that's that should be our new intro it'd
be nice
we have that band
i know we need jazz we need jazz up
front
so any jazz jazz vibe send us something
you know gerard carmichael just recorded
his uh special at the blue note i was
like man that's pretty that's pretty
badass
small room but much like him his set was
uh improvised
all right he's very jazzy you know he's
very
artsy fartsy
i love this song great tune you guys the
best we love you thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]
like a cop's coming and naked samuel is
feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
[Music]
[Music]